the race for personal protective
equipment California has a wide-ranging
agreement to buy PPE
for its medical workers and governor
Gavin Newsom signed this deal reported
the cost nearly 1 billion dollars and he
did it out of a frustration he said with
the federal response a Department of
Health and Human Services report this
week echos urgent calls from hospitals
for more supplies one administrator
cited a three to six-month delay for
essential items including those critical
n95 face masks our doctor Jon LaPook
looks in the PPE supply chain we don't
have enough I mean it's it's it's you
know 195 mask for the entire for the
entire ship every day when I go to work
I feel like a sheep going to slaughter
these are the battle cries of doctors
and nurses on the front lines fighting
coronavirus without the proper armor
this right here is my mask
for the whole day but how did we get
here
where health care workers have to fight
for PPE so they can fight the virus
without getting infected themselves we
are all shopping China to try to get
these materials and we're all competing
against each other a large portion of
the u.s. PPE supply like gloves gowns
and masks comes from China
prashant yard of is a senior fellow at
the Center for Global Development and an
expert on supply chain management we use
at least half all war comes from China
two million or two billion two billion
and is that each year yes as coronavirus
cases rose in China earlier this year
yard of says PPE production took a hit
even as demand for it spiked large
supply distributors told US hospitals it
could be months before their orders were
met the links in the supply chain had
been broken federal stockpile are almost
depleted state level stop hands hold
limited supplies and distributors not
being able to deliver
in 95 in any significant quantity for
three to six weeks states and the
federal government stepped in to help
find and buy PPE but that's led to
bidding wars it's like being on eBay
with 50 other states states are
competing against states right now
that's no secret we're all competing
against each other states one against
another federal government competing
against States President Trump has
insisted he is sending States what they
need since last Sunday cargo planes have
delivered almost listen to this
300 million gloves almost eight million
masks and three million gowns a
Department of Homeland Security official
told CBS News the strategic national
stockpile of protective gear is almost
depleted last week President Trump
invoked the defense production act
ordering private companies to help
manufacture ventilators and n95 face
masks but it could still be weeks before
hospitals get the PPE and donations
aren't always enough the nation isn't
ready to provide medical care and large
catastrophes or big epidemics of
contagious disease experts have said for
years if a global pandemic were to hit
the u.s. may not have enough PPE public
health is about over planning Beth
Cameron ran the White House pandemic
response office under the Obama and
Trump administrations it was dissolved
by the White House in 2018 and she
believes that move left the country less
prepared I'm really worried about the
competition between states it's the
thing that keeps me up at night right
now I think that in the absence of a
unified federal plan states don't have
any choice but to be prepared for their
constituents in your opinion what entity
is best prepared to do that kind of
unified plan I like to see a logistics
are at this point to be honest with you
in my opinion and I think that logistics
are could come from the military or it
could be a former military commander we
were gonna need a plan for moving and
sharing medical equipment across the
United States and I hope that we don't
need to use that plan but I think if we
have that plan we're not gonna regret it
for those on the frontlines it's a
matter of life or death if we did have
enough PPE
we wouldn't be forced to use the m95
over and over again we can't do our jobs
effectively if we aren't safe we're not
safe and therefore you're not safe and
so if you don't have health care workers
you cannot save lives you've heard that
they've had to reuse the n95 mess
because there's such precious
commodities and that's led medical
centers across the country to try to
figure out ways of repurposing them of
sanitizing them but like so many other
things in this outbreak we're trying to
figure it out on the fly as we go Tony
yeah John we're definitely in whatever
it takes
territory with this crisis thank you
very much